[Laughter]
random characters are so crazy on this
show i know i know
mister whatever white's so greasy
christianity again after cowboys
you went all the way back around oh god
why can't i die
this is music
welcome back to new rockstars rick and
morty season five episode two broke our
brains
yet again by revealing there isn't just
an infinite number of ricks and smith
families across the multiverse but
within each of those universes
an infinite number of decoy families all
trying to kill each other
seriously
this is rick explained our rick and
morty after show where we overthink rick
and morty to give you the hot take so
that you can post them and rise to the
top of
eric and marty baby my easter egg
breakdown of all the details you missed
is coming tomorrow so don't comment on
this video
saying that i missed something do that
on tomorrow's video dum-dum but
here i am with rick and morty super fan
and a copy of a copy who only ripens
with duplication tommy bechtold
hey eric i'm just here on a family
vacation
in beautiful pleasanton california oh
god the squids are here
i knew you're you're with a decoy ah
well now we're gonna have to host a
decoy tommy that's fine
he's not as good but we'll take him um
so this is a wild episode i did have to
watch it a couple times to fully process
what happened
uh so tommy remind us all what happened
oh my god well we got started off with a
bang
the smith family is suddenly
assassinated by advanced alien squids
but it's revealed it's just a decoy
family rick created
beth criticizes rick for continuing to
clone family members after doing so to
her
last season but rex doesn't learn
lessons we know that not at all
he's not going to change more and more
decoy families are killed in hilarious
fashion until rick realizes
his decoys have been making their own
decoys leading to what he calls an
asimov cascade a chain reaction where
the infinite decoy families
try to kill each other yeah of course it
has this
natural of course as you as you do the
squids are then revealed to also be
other decoy families in disguise
what is going on talk about wtf i was
like all right
my brain is broken the decoy family is
heightened into monstrous
scarecrow families who harvest skin a
wooden puppet family
yeah with the voice boxes in there like
it was just getting copy of a copy of a
copy until it's just down to like
nothing
oh my god so one rick lights a beacon to
invite all decoy families
into an all-out melee as it should be
rick apologizes to beth and this is
in this family seems to be the final
family standing until they're killed
by mr always wants to be hunted
somebody haunt me i can't wait till
we can go to comic-cons again to buy a
mister he always wants to be hunted
with a cute little target on his chest
and what appears to be vaseline all over
his back yeah i know
it's just greased up he's like it's just
easier to be slippery
yeah exactly meanwhile our smith family
has been in space
this whole time with the returning space
bath answering our questions from last
week
and in the post-credits scene wood and
jerry is unable to die
and realize his history loops around to
cowboys and christianity
all right aaron but we have to know how
many decoy families
does rick have yeah i actually counted
the numbers interesting
before we get to that if you like our
rick and morty coverage and all the
other content we make here at new
rockstars one of the best ways you can
support us is to check out our merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we have this line of exclusive loki
inspired merch based on the hit disney
plush show obviously
you know what it is i assume uh it
includes an augmented reality shirt as
well
that sounds like something rick sanchez
might have grafted under his skin but
you know it's a real thing that you can
wear and impress your friends with so
support this channel
get yourself some cool swag and uh you
won't find it anywhere else
just go to newrockstarsmerch.com but
yeah let's talk about this question
tommy how many
decoy families are in existence that we
see from this episode
well the implication would be infinite
you know there's enough to suggest that
there are infinite numbers right
um but if you count this episode does
present a finite number
and that number is interesting because i
counted exactly 89.
why is that interesting well halfway
through the episode after gunning down
what he thinks
is a squid ship rick says all right hey
one down probably
what 40 more to go 45 and he doesn't
realize that that ship is another decoy
family in disguise so if you consider
that there are as many
undisguised decoy families as squid
disguised ones
the actual number would probably be
around double that around 90.
so 89 is one short of 90 and there might
be a 90th
uh 90th rick i'll explain my theory for
what that could be in a moment
also when rick explains the asimov
cascade principle and just so we're
clear he's referencing isaac asimov he's
a irobot author he's like a sci-fi
thinker he kind of coined the laws of
robotics and explored ai sentience as a
theme and he concluded that sentient ai
will probably inevitably turn on its
creator as we see in this episode
um but if you look closely at that
whiteboard there's one equation that
doesn't make sense it says 008 equals
889.
um that's not math that's not how it
works but
uh i think what this could mean is the
puppet disguised family at the end of
the episode
the one that we have this cathartic
moment between beth and rick
at um we think that is the 89th family
that
as i was doing my counting but it's
actually the same family as the family
we saw in the cold open the one that was
hunting mr always wants to be hunted and
that's how he recognizes mr always wants
to be hunted at the end
so that even though is the second one we
see in the episode
that might be like the eighth decoy
family so eight
equals 89 889 like there's
over uh you know 800 other things right
it's just saying that like i think it's
setting up that the family that we saw
at the beginning is gonna come back we
think it's like a higher number but it's
actually the one that's coming back
right
but i'm gonna speed through how i got to
the number i got to we got the cold open
family that's the one that plans to kill
god
ironically rick number two later claims
to be a god and
is killed by the end of this episode so
in a way they do kind of kill god
uh in a roundabout way uh family two is
the family that plays mr always wants to
be hunted
fourth is the one vacation in italy the
fifth is uh when
morty and rick are watching wen wolf on
interdimensional people
i love that kind of rooted for me that
they would
love what did they say about the vampire
they're like i would have rather seen
when wolf go back to the 1920s and
invest in stocks and then eat people of
course
people yeah which i feel like there's
got to be a meta
reflection of their own insecurities as
writers like stick to your core concept
the core concept is multiverse rick's
not
like decoy family ricks which kind of
it's kind of the same thing but done
in a different way so uh sixth family is
the rick who we stay with this group for
a while that's the rick who farts on
morty with the barcode
trick and then uh that's the rick that
first realizes decoys are making their
own decoys this is where things get a
little confusing if you're trying to
follow it uh
the the seventh family is that decoy
family that rick six finds and they have
the passcode of 80085 which is boobs
and and calculator uh elite um and then
the
eighth family is the second decoy family
that family six finds they have the
passcode that our rick doesn't know and
it's eight
equals equal sign d which is just the
the dick the emoji
uh and then uh the ninth family
is the family that created that uh that
family the eight family
uh and then the tenth family is the one
who lava melts them all and then they
discuss the azimov cascade
and they first make the stitch together
the crappy squid costumes
uh they find family 11 which is a better
dress squid disguise family now
up until now i have not been counting
the other squid assassins just because
we see a ton of squid assassin families
later who i do count and i think it's
safe to assume that one of those
assassins was the one that we later see
so i don't want to double up
family 12 was uh randomly the rick who
shocks a creature in poops candy
that's such a weird moment but i loved
it he's so proud of himself too yeah
and the creature's enjoying it it's like
he loves it
we see two uh families 13 14 that's
where there's a family living room and
then there's another drive-by that
happens
uh family 15 rick performs brain surgery
on himself that could have been one of
the other ones we see but i'm assuming
anytime we see a new one in a montage a
new family it's not a squid assassin i'm
just going to count that as a new family
right
uh we see three ricks in a hallway 16 17
18. 19
is one where summer like cuts herself to
think she's human but rick just reveals
she cries 20 to 21 we see the shot of
two squid ricks and ships one shoots
himself
uh and then we pivot to family 22 they
try to live off grid in the spooky
haunted forest
uh and then 23 is the murderous
scarecrow family
uh it's kind of like buffalo bill uh
texas chainsaw massacre kind of
situation uh and then
um if you look closely around that
murder castle you see
uh four other pass ricks that rick 23
had killed that
pinned up next to rick 22 and then in
addition to that
10 other rick skins are visible hanging
overhead and i just count by the ricks
there are other members of the family
that are piled up but if you know that
there's a rick that was a whole other
family
so that's 30 we're up to 37 now 38 is
the wooden family who saves them
and then brings them to this refuge the
cause and
uh if you count by the summers summer is
the the highest frequency member of the
family there are 14
other summers in there 15 if you include
the one who just came there
i'm also not counting the wooden one so
uh that
brings us up to 53. uh and then uh some
squid family must have bombed this
refuge 54. the mexican beach family
uh that's 55. the family that bombs them
and then we follow them for a while
that's 56 that's the one who lights the
beacon
and then we see a bunch of uh families
soar into this
um first there's like some who look up
and see the beacon
one is like uh it looks like a basket
version of them that are drawing the
whole asimov cascade in the dirt
which i love that um because they suck
and then uh and then like 17 more ships
fly back to join the battle and then
later from space
12 more come in so we're at 88 now now
when you're watching the melee i don't
think you see more families than 29
families which is the number of families
who fly in
in various shots so i'm just going to
count it at 29.
uh and then we uh find the puppet
disguise family that we think is the
89th family
uh but that's actually the second family
that we saw back in the cold open
so the true 89th family is our man main
family that
has been up in space on adventure with
space bath this whole time so
89 i guess you could say 88 decoys from
the 89th family but the theme of this
episode is that family could be a decoy
of one of the others
who's a decoy and who is it right now
this 90th
family there's this whole great moment
where jerry
questions the logic of mr always wants
to be hunted yeah uh
and like why like i think we should be
asking more about that and then rick
shuts them down when really jerry was
right by the end of the episode they
should have been on the lookout for mr
always want to be hunted and why he
wants to be hunted
uh and jerry mentions that he comes from
a cryotube
uh and i am wondering if this could be
like
another decoy that rick created of a guy
with a
target on him right that was from a
cryotube that was maybe just like
too much of a copy of a copy or like a
failed decoy experiment that's why he's
so greasy as he just has this genetic
defect
so so rick just painted a target on him
and he's like oh go go
there's always one who ended so i think
that's the theme of it it's like the
the most failed experiment is one you
have to keep your eye on
because he's the most imperfect and then
rick's perfection in his like
over perfectionism is what undid him in
this
most definitely so my theory is that mr
always wants to be hunted
is a rick decoy a real watered down one
just a very very diminished return
but i love this idea i mean it breaks
people's brains because we already
had this kind of um ironic detachment
right this uh existential
um whatever feeling about the show as
soon as
you know season one they revealed that
there was a multiverse and a citadel of
ricks
it began a similar way where rick was
shot in the head at the breakfast table
right uh and then it expanded that way
and this is kind of doing the same thing
but staying within a universe which is
just
even harder to um to conceive in a way
because now it's like how do they not
run into each other
right well yeah i mean he says he
mentions that he programs them to live
like
pleasant lives or something like that
right like they all have like
so maybe maybe the whoever the one true
rick is
he knows what their programs are so he
can avoid
maybe he's you know he's so smart it
would stand to reason that he's
programmed them to never run into each
other but they must just be all over the
country right we see in the map like
yeah there's one in every state there
might be two in every state i don't know
just hide them all in wyoming there's no
one there right right and
that's the decoys that he knew about
right like there are others you know i
think that was kind of the implication
of it
there's one in baja there was one like
off the coast of florida like in the
water there
right like on a yacht or something right
i like that
the yacht smiths that are just out there
cruising in
in the caribbean uh but i think the idea
is that all these decoys have maybe been
wiped out but like at the end of the day
like the fact that the rick we stay with
could very well be a decoy
i think it even pushes the show further
in this direction of don't get
attached to any one rick even though
there is some continuity for sure
episode episode or across seasons that
the morning
we've been following is the c-137 morty
and rick who arrived after rick potion
number nine
uh and you know presumably in the same
way that we could have been following a
different universe episode episode we
could have been following a different
decoy episode to episode
but realistically there has been some
continuity i think the writers would say
it doesn't matter
at the end of the day right but uh we do
have some more questions coming out of
this episode
uh first we want to thank some people
who helped us make it starting with our
friends at helix sleep
you don't want to sleep on a mattress
designed for someone else
even if that person is the darkest
timeline version of yourself they
probably like a super firm mattress and
always sleep on the side of their body
without the eye patch
well helix sleep is a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
they have soft medium and burn
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers i
have a helix mattress and i
love it the quiz matched me with a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
sleeps cool
that's right i'm sleeping like i'm
living yeah yeah
cool and sometimes sitting up in a cold
sweat
over anxiety yeah oh yeah
but not it's not the mattresses of fault
the mattress is working hard to
to lull this baby back to sleep um so
here's what you do go to
helixsleep.com ricksplained take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the
best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.complain
this show is also sponsored by
betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
we've all been there at some point
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help
it's a professional counseling it's
professional counseling done securely
online
there is a broad range of expertise
available for clients worldwide
in to your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor you won't ever
have to sit in an uncomfortable waiting
room or
look for parking better help makes it
easy and free to change counselors if
you need to it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
better wants you to start living a
happier life today so visit
betterhelp.com that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken advantage of their mental
health with the help of it
oh not advantage to join the over 1
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using better help
that they are recruiting additional
counselors in all 50 states
special offer for explained audience get
10 percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com
ricksplained all right tommy what is our
next question as we look ahead in this
episode well so eric we already
did discuss this a little bit but let's
let's really hammer down our thoughts on
this if all the decoys live on the same
earth how do they not cross paths or
realize their homes are in different
neighborhoods
yeah so as you said tommy they do
mention this episode that like
each decoy is kind of programmed it's
designed to kind of just
accept their neighborhood as normal you
know
and it's like they're given false
memories as well so that they never
question it yeah they specifically
reference
westworld which is if you've watched
westworld you know
that these ai are incredibly realistic
incredibly intelligent incredibly
intuitive
but they're also their built-in blind
spots so they can't see
or they do see doors that aren't really
there or they or they don't see doors
that exist they see blank walls so that
stands to reason
if rick was serious about them having
kind of like westworld technology
maybe these things are these these
decoys are built to not
really know any better to question it
you know yeah
exactly uh and i think for some viewers
that might undercut
the sense that any of these decoys could
have been the rick that we're following
because if they are
stuck in narrative loops like in west
world with like
false memories uh program memories
program perception
then like were did they they never truly
had free will
they were only really going on
adventures that wouldn't allow them to
interfere
but also if there's an infinite number
of decoys wouldn't you know
realistically
one bump into one that was designed by a
different race right but i think
i think the answer to this one uh tommy
is that this all happened really fast
right
like i'm wondering if our main rick that
we've been following c137 rick who's
been up in space
he might have designed his first decoy
relatively recently
and then because rick is just so
brilliant right it all snowballed
within a span of like 12 hours just
because ricks are just
that way by nature and he had not yet
like he didn't think it would happen
this fast realistically
you know so i think the idea is maybe we
haven't had decoys since the beginning
of the series
i think it's probably like a recent
thing rick tried out and then the joke
of it is
whoa that escalated quickly right you
know right right right yeah
and then what we're seeing now is that
chaos that you're talking about should
have been happening before it's just
happening now right because it was just
a recent it's just all
can't opened up the proverbial can of
worms as they say
uh now since this episode ends in such a
um
i don't know a theological place of like
christianity came back did rick
you think tommy in a roundabout way end
up killing god this episode and that's
why they had christianity come back just
to show that
christianity cannot be killed yeah at
the end of the day like michael myers
but i
yeah you know i i think well one they
had the literal rick saying he was a god
that ends up getting killed right so
he's right
exactly but then we also have like rick
kind of
the the concept of creating life and i
think what do they say you just love
creating sentences
or you get hard creating sentient life
and then he says you know i get hard
saving my family
and they're like oh that's not any
better but i think like yeah
like they kind of they've killed god
over and over and over and over again
in this episode because it was like you
know everyone or at least
got god's people they thought were gods
because the
whoever thought they were the main rick
creating the decoys that kept getting
killed
in their mind that was a god getting
killed you know in my
my interpretation so yeah killing your
creator is uh you know it's like the
promethean argument
right define your god yeah right so i
guess i guess the answer as always with
rick and morty is
kind of yeah and i think that's you kind
of know that's it's gonna be going in
this direction
because like even though the show has
kind of an
atheistic undertone as all science
fiction kind of does
um not all but a lot of it um if it's
like chaos theory
but the uh the show does have like a
um a reverence to higher powers i think
they don't want to be too
um disrespectful or too irreverent uh
and like when he opens the episode
saying we're going to kill god it's kind
of like
okay rick's going to suffer this right
yeah something bad's going to happen
i think they do a great job of
taking the smugness that often
and i don't mean all atheists obviously
i know plenty of atheists in my life who
are wonderful people
but often the attachment of atheism in
fictional media
comes across as so smug and all-knowing
and definitive
they do a great job of being like nobody
really knows anything like
the more hubris you kind of have of
intelligence on any one topic
the more likely you are to have some
sort of bad downfall in the rick and
morty
world agreed yeah and i think that goes
for anything in life like
we go through this weird i don't know if
it's a bell-shaped curve i think it is
bell-shaped you gain knowledge you gain
knowledge you gain knowledge and
the more knowledge you gain the more you
realize you don't know right right right
and you're more okay with yourself
you'll never know yeah yeah and that's
why
i felt like you know going through
college and high school i'm just like
oh we're all just gonna like pretend
that
that it's all [ __ ] right right okay
but because i mean like science tells us
and then as you get older and life
experience hits you it's like oh no i
get why
uh most older folks in my life go to
church absolutely because
there's a need for that yeah and also i
mean like let's just get down to brass
tacks they serve donuts regularly
hell yeah baby that's the reason you go
is her that
donut sit through an hour's speech and
get some donuts what are the
what's the worst thing that could happen
that's right hell yeah baby
so i have a question for you tommy so we
realized this episode that these squid
assassins are really just like
costumes worn by other decoy ricks at
some point
some decoy rick or some creator rick
thought
yeah squids let's let's do that why do
you think squids were chosen by rick
like if we can get inside his head
there's two
i have two thoughts one there's such a
weird
in sci-fi especially like futuristic
sci-fi
obsession with squid-shaped aliens like
who's the guy that did like
you know all the all the art for uh
aliens like
famously i forget oh oh geiger hr
like there's that his obsession with
squids but also
for me it was just a call back to the
first episode
when uh when they killed mr nimbus
signature contract witness that was the
squid
right was that a squid or an octopus i
don't remember but i think it was a
squid because it had
squid ink and he signed the contract
with the squid ink and then
then that squid ends up getting shot in
the head and i was like yeah yeah
last week yeah i kept expecting that to
be the payoff
before the reveal that the the squids
were just decoys
disguise the squids i was like this is
gonna be some tie-in to
mr nimbus getting revenge for murdering
his
his signature witness who was also his
friend
so i don't know if i i think ultimately
probably the first thing i said is
closer to it like you know there's just
a
sci-fi and squid-shaped things have
always gone hand-in-hand as like you
know
it's a scary put on a grand scale
a squid looks scary and intimidating but
i also wonder if it was just a nod to
the first episode
no i think i like that idea a lot tommy
because i think
uh at least you can imagine some rick or
some rick decoy
thinking like my i will be able to fool
the other ones
by thinking there's this revenge plot
from mr nemesis
or whatever yeah so like their evolved
like parent species
are are coming to get revenge right like
just trying rick trying to
play 40 chess and outsmart himself is
one of the funniest things to be like
it always devolves into something stupid
which is squids
with like vagina-shaped heads right
let's be honest they all have like
phallic or everything on that show
either looks like a butthole
a vagina or a penis there's just yeah
right at the end of the day that's where
it all heightens too which i think is so
funny yeah and i also think there's some
irony that like these squids have like
they're what is it hexapods six legs
because squids don't have eight occupy
everything but uh but this idea of like
one becomes many of like one
rick has like at least six decoys that
he made i
like the drawing of the asimov cascade
did kind of have like a pyramid scheme
looking yeah
a shape to it um but i just love this
idea that he settled on squid i know uh
and that you see the stages of
crappiness as they got better at making
squid costumes which is just really
funny yeah the first ones were just like
mascot costumes at a shitty theme park
yeah
yeah um all right we have one more
sponsor we want to thank our friends at
magic spoon thanks to magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode so most folks
would like to eat better right but
healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring
magic spoon has the amazing flavors that
you love but without all the bad stuff
there's zero grams of sugar 13 to 14
grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving only 140 calories a
serving and it's keto friendly gluten
free grain free
soy free low carb and gmo free so get
yourself a variety pack of the four
flavors of cocoa fruity frosted and
peanut butter
my personal preference is for fruity but
i've heard some tale
of folks mixing cocoa and peanut butter
together
for a diy peanut butter cup flavor
so go to magicspoon.com to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
ricksplain to check out to save five
dollars off your order and magic spoon
is so confident in their product it is
backed with a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember
get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
explained and used the code rick
explained to save five dollars off
and thank you to magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode so let's talk
about this uh
this post-credits scene one of the best
post-credits scenes
i think i love it when we just follow
jerry down a rabbit never
it's always comedy gold right it's like
it's always great if we're following
jerry
something really chris parnell's voice
work which is like
it's just his voice but sad just
defeated
it's just chris parnell doing his voice
but as if
all of the happiness has exited his life
and he's trying his best to still appear
happy like yeah even when jerry's
optimistic there's still a twinge of
sadness to it
exactly yeah he plays it so well uh and
i wonder if like the fact that he
is immortal through the end of all time
this applies to the main continuity of
the series
does this mean every future episode has
has wooden sherry somewhere in the
background screaming as a woodpecker is
going away
oh i want more yes i want one and jerry
to come back i'm sure he will
right we gotta check in with him even if
he's just like some wooden
form like a a whittling workshop at
disneyland or something
i want one jerry to be in the background
yes me too i love this idea
uh and let's end on this idea of space
beth i think ultimately this episode was
kind of the writer's attempt to uh
explore the
implications of rick cloning family
members
um and this whole episode is kind of a
debate of like it's not a clone it's a
decoy but essentially yeah
he is like cloning family members and
himself right for and just seeing where
this goes
uh and then at the end of the episode um
spacebeth says you know don't get too
excited
let's not get too worked up over me
coming back right so are we think
we're done i think this is just them
saying like this is why
we don't want uh to explore clone beth
too much
because we're just going to run out the
logical implementations
it gets repetitive because you're like
you know i mean it's fun
and the writers are so brilliant they're
always going to make it funny but at a
certain point you're like
all right so i get it at any point any
person having a conversation could get
shot in the head
be revealed to be a clone and then a new
thing starts
not dissimilarly to the stress it's it's
like the
it's the non-stressful version of the
way the boys was last season where
you're like
many conversations head could explode at
any time and so i'm just kind of always
on edge watching these people but it's
like yeah
it kind of loses its uh importance if it
just continues to happen so like i think
yeah moving away
there's so much other fun stuff they can
explore it's time to probably move away
from that for a bit at least
yeah and i think the writers were aware
of this limit that they had by
exploring this concept i will say as
watching it i love the speed of it every
time i watch the show i'm in awe of how
much story they pack into it
but i think you do kind of start to
divest in it emotionally after too long
and uh and there was at some point in
this episode i'm just like huh
uh like i i'm still loving what i'm
seeing it's still
funny as hell right but like i just did
lose
track of like whose story i was
following
and like they bring it back when rick
apologized to beth but then i just feel
like oh the writers are just trying to
be too responsive to
uh finding a way out of their own corner
with with space beth when i didn't
really need that like
i don't um so i to me people are
comparing this to other like
you know the citadel of rick's episode
the the first citadel of rick's in uh
season one
and total recall i would probably rank
total recall higher just because
uh we know all those memories are false
right and then it's kind of neatly tied
up by the end of the episode
this kind of just leaves it open it's
not as like logically
uh airtight as you recall was yeah i
think for sure
yeah i agree that's okay we have a great
time he is still amazing
still hilarious still wouldn't jerry
being the cross that future christ gets
nailed to you
oh my god freaking wild ah
so uh we'll leave it there that's it for
this episode of ricksplained my easter
egg breakdown
of all the little details you missed in
the episode again is coming tomorrow
uh tommy and i will be back next week to
react to episode three
so be sure to follow tommy at tommy bech
told follow me at eavos follow me
rockstars subscribe to ricksplained
wherever you get your podcasts
thank you for watching we will close
with our favorite moment of the episode
christianity hasn't been invented yet
crosses are just baby tees to me now i
got out
please don't invite me back in
[Music]
you